end game as name suggests will be
about end games and i will continue but
essentially essentially what happened
uh what i was doing last time as this
lecture and i
as a reminder last time i talked about
some of my end games from us
championships i talked about my game
against
sam savian and some shankaland both very
interesting rugen games
and both and withdraws
right now i'm i will show something some
other games
something some games that i'm not really
proud of
but hopefully
you know the if you guys are watching
you can learn from my mistakes
and yeah so
all right um let's just start the
let's start with this game against my
game against alejandra ramirez
and here in the opening after the
opening actually
probably from this position because this
was very long end game it was
uh the game last like 70 or 80 moves
after the opening i simply got such
horrible position as black
and um in here
um i mean unfortunately i made mistakes
in the opening
and mixed up some lines and i found
myself
in defending such position which is
obviously terrible
first of all white has pair of bishops
and
[Music]
pretty simple play like bones are on the
both sides of the board
it uh also my opponent c6 doesn't quite
help because we can further the other
dark squares
um basically i'm forced to be you know
the thing till the end of the game
pretty much
so uh but i was like okay let's it's
rapid chess i can maybe
you know try to hold it solid and
eventually somehow
survive but yeah
anyway so white is on the move right now
i play
100 bishop before a very nice move with
an id4
and in this position knight d2 was one
of the let's say normal moves another
another possibility for white
in such positions would be to play 94
idea
is to key design from e4 with f3
and this was very decent alternative and
very often not always but many instances
i would say that uh coordination you
know like you know two pair of bishops
uh with the knight versus let's say uh
you know two knights and the bishop or
something like this
it is um way easier for
for the cycles pair of bishops in such
instance uh to create threats and
put less oppression on the opponent of
course it's not always they're
like it's just kind of you know it is
considered like this
but of course 92 doesn't spoil anything
who is a very very good move is what is
much better huge advantage positionally
knight xd2 bishop takes d2 uh alternate
was king takes d2 but
and but it could be to make sense
because alhamdulillah was just one just
to castle alongside and
uh you know just
then develop quickly the rook instead of
king d2
uh knight and to here i'd play knight b6
where i have bishop e6
long castle bishop b6 so in this
position okay b3
so in this position uh my as i said
earlier my only
goal right now as a side who is the
defending is to play
as solid as i can try to hold it
together not to make any further
weaknesses and
hope that eventually my difference will
be will be sufficient to maintain
a draw because white's advantage is
only positional is there is no like
extra pawn or anything
it is just pair of bishops but this
purpose is actually
very very powerful and i knew that
during the game
and but you know i got myself in such
position so i had to
sort of fight so my defensive idea here
uh was to play uh
most important what i understood the
most important thing is to
keep protected all the entrant points on
the default and e file
that he cannot access invade with his
rooks
on seventh rank for instance
if i'm afforded if i manage to do this
it will be
not so clear at least at first sight how
to make progress
this is what i started doing basically i
played f6
bishop d3 king f7 um
will be it will be probably a mistake to
go long castle
because then my king is not really
supporting the e file
and it is easier either sort of a little
bit to control the d7 squared and e7
square so i want to make sure that only
seven are also well guarded
so f6 bishop d3 king f7 c4
all natural moves knight d7 um minor b6
doesn't do anything i have to move my
net back knight d7
bishop e3 and now uh a6 alternative
would be to play a5 but as i said
in i think as a general you know
strategy such positions avoid making
further mistakes if a6 right now
uh makes position solid i want to at
some point bring the rook
of course i could have done it
immediately but the most important thing
was mapping just to keep it solid so a6
definitely serves up this purpose
maybe i was planning to simplify the b5
sometimes
not sure probably not and i didn't do it
eventually as we'll see
but uh you know i keep at least maybe
some idea like this a6 can be two
rook he8 h3 all natural moves
uh in general in such end games the
strategy
for the side who has advantage
is
[Music]
do not hurry do not rush things and
if you do not rush things you slowly
gonna improve the position
and eventually increase the pressure and
increase the advantage
uh just do it slowly do not rush things
don't rush russian complications
because all of them will be probably
probably premature and then it will
like will give us the defending side
some chances
in in this position i decided to play h5
and i tried as black to create maybe
some contour on the on the
king side um maybe fix the pawn
structure maybe create some weakness on
the queen side
sorry king side of course it's very you
know
far-fetched to say the least but i have
to play
something i have to make some moves so
at least i thought it would be maybe
probably
good practical try bishop v2 g6
rook d6 a very nice move and
here the very important idea here from
black's perspective
is to make sure that this that i kicked
this rook out of d6
and i found interesting maneuver of
bringing my knight to
f7 and i played move knight e5 and here
i had
a small trick if i remember correctly
uh of um
oh it was at this position uh
yeah it was no it was an explosion after
d1 kg7 here i had
some small trick i prepared a small
trick that
if f4
basically chasing my knight away um
i could basically remove my knight and
there'll be some issues on the e file
so a forest would be premature and there
is no rush to ever
push this pawn whenever you know there
could be some tactics
so um the point is
after diwan kim sen again i have played
very well king c3
just slowly increase the pressure and
king c3 comes also a very powerful idea
right now from for white
can be four king five king b sorry
because king c6 king b6
and essentially my phone b7 becomes
a big big weakness and if he if he
manages to bring his king to b6 very
likely pawn b7
will eventually just fall because i will
not be able to hold
my defenses there first of all if my
keys on d7
uh all my pieces will be totally cramped
because of the such powerful looks on
the d file
so probably i have to keep my knight on
f7 but if i kill him and keep mine at an
f7
the king comes too easily to b6 so
pretty much there is no good
defense and objectively white with
correct
techniques correct play white should
eventually win this game
and uh i was a little bit surprised when
i was analyzing this game
and that engines evaluate this person is
totally winning for white like plus
plus one and a half plus two even though
material balance is equal
it's just uh that positionally black's
push is so bad
but uh you know over the board i i just
had no idea of course about such
evaluations i would just try to make
moves
and survive as long as i could so knight
f7 looks logical
rook d2 h4 and bishop b6 knight g5
trying to get to e4 of course it's this
period immediately f3
and right now if i if i play bishop f5
bishop f2 would simply lose the pawn so
i have to go back to my knight to f7
and here we have the one very
interesting position
and in which i think alejandra made
small inaccuracy
so far he played perfect chess uh but
here i thought he made a slight
inaccuracy of course it's not like uh
it's
dropping the majority of advantage or
something like that
but uh at least what i was worried
during the game was that
alhamdulillah would play here move
bishop d3 and the idea of bishop d3 is
that with this bishop on the frame i can
never activate my bishop from a from e6
and let's say he can bring his bishop
back to c2
then simply push his king forward and
there is nothing
i could really do that i could see at
least and also during the analysis say
95
bishop c2 and i know if g5 for instance
there is possibility to play immediately
f4
after uh g takes a 4 rook f1 pawn f4
simply false
and along with a four point h4 pawn will
fall and f6 will be a weakness
so this this destroys completely my pawn
structure on the king side and the game
is pretty much decided already
so i cannot do that
and if i just stay in place oh like what
am i doing then like i'm just
waiting place don't doing anything of
course there'll be some progress made
a4 let's say on rook ac8 or something a5
slowly pushing forward
king comes maybe to c5 right now f4 is
another
good move knight h6 trying to get to f5
or something but king before we can just
i can just ignore that if ever bishops
are traded on f5
i can never do that i would really love
to but i can't because after this this
rook d7 captures b7 and the game is
already you know
lost so i can also trade my bishops like
this
so i if knight f7 just bishop f2 upon h4
is hanging rook aj and finally king's
[ __ ] b6 comes
and with such small uh but constant
progress what
would basically gain simply you know
overwhelming advantage and
without any even simple counterplay for
black because after what happened in the
game
uh bishop f1 allows me bishop f5
and i thought that if i managed to
activate this bishop slightly i may have
some hope for counterplay bishop d3 is
kind of like you know the move that you
want to play right now
first of all because it's not as strong
as it was before the straight because
i can maybe play uh rookie seven rookie
eight
or also i can confide look for can't
play after the same bishop d3
i may start looking for counter play
with movie rookie two which is
by far the main my main point right now
and
it may be not entirely easy of course
while it's still much better i can maybe
move my knight to e5 back
while it's still much better but it's
becoming less and less clear and this is
what
i was hoping for i have never played kim
before of course white is still much
better is just
it's my life got a little bit easier if
i got my bishop to f5
i play right now g5 and
but right now i think alexander made
others
inaccuracy uh probably their
their it was the by the the cost for
all the inaccuracies and mistakes in all
those games were basically
sure that was basically shorter time
control i remember here i had slightly
more time than him
and uh maybe he was under some pressure
or something like this time pressure
once or whatever
here if you play her by king a5 i
i don't know what i'm doing to be honest
the skin comes to b6 i can't really stop
that
rookie 5 or just c5
i know rookie 8 just bishop c7 suddenly
looks if i just keep b6
so yeah this is just basically game
uh over because i guess i give the c5
one but
only seven is gone and with it
everything all the pawns king has been
some pretty funny king but there i
cannot
quite cannot attack this king in any
possible way on the dark side white
simply
is dominating and anytime king can come
to come back to b6 will be perfectly
safe
um so yeah like i i don't know what
what i would do and it moves like uh
rookie seven which sort of
uh makes sense still allow me to move
like bishop d8
and uh it doesn't quite so even trade of
those bishops uh will not be
uh i'm first not known right now we can
well i can do it right now but it
wouldn't be optimal but the first white
can play the same bishop c4 let's say
after this bishop t would be one of the
ideas also it's possible to just make
some way to move like a4 and so on maybe
rook d4 slowly improve the position
eventually white black will run out of
moves all possibilities play rook d4 and
f4 for instance such plan
lots of ideas here for white and black
is
sort of just you know waiting for
execution to be honest
rookie 2 happened though and this was
inaccuracy and after 95
still king a5 was just much much better
uh same ideas apply king comes to
eventually b6 i cannot really stop that
sooner or later but 100 bishop c7 and
suddenly
this move uh would have given me great
chances to survive the game because if
you look at
position two moves earlier let's put
this one
in this position white pieces are
perfectly placed they're
totally coordinated bishop on f1 maybe
it's not not perfect but you know solid
rooks are connected the king is on
before should just go it should just go
forward
bishop on v6 also is um you know
dominating piece
um but after two moves are made rookie
295 king
sorry bishop c7 suddenly
while the groups are not already
coordinated bishop on f1
is you know also still not even it was
even worse than and then it was before
because the three square is
now available for some checks uh bishop
my c7
um i don't know what was the purpose of
bishop 7 because if bishop e5
i i'm happy to trade so suddenly
becoming is becoming a little bit kind
of shaky for uh
for white and i had here a poor
opportunity to
maybe not equalize but at least make uh
alejandro's task
much much harder and i could play move
a5 so this is what i'm trying to say
some very very very often um
it is very very important to look for
dynamic
ideas uh especially when you are worse
try to look for let's say dynamic ideas
to solve your problems
uh because some very if you just keep
waiting white
or like you know the side is you know
better or like you know has
advantage will eventually consolidate
and there will not be any such ideas
available
so if you have a moment to go look for
counterplay just
do it because
otherwise you're gonna be just suffering
till the end of the game so a5 right now
was a
very interesting tribe by for me which i
of course
unfortunately didn't play because i um
first of all i didn't play this
tournament great i think i didn't play
which has greatest in this tournament
second thing
it was rapid chess which a5 requires a
lot of calculation and i
didn't see there is need for such moves
uh
so i just disappeared something solid
but yeah but a5 right now will basically
put loads of pressure on
on alejandro i think because there are
basically
two options take on a5 or do not take on
a5 if not take on i5 then
king c5 uh or king c3 or maybe king a4
or
king a3 i analyzed the few of those
moves i analyzed let's say for instance
let's see if you don't take the pawn
king c3 let's say seems like solid move
suddenly we get to play b5 and we can
see that this with this rook on e2 this
bishop on the form of one is covered and
right now we can
well i can hope for a very active
counter we'll counter play with b5
of course white would never want to take
because suddenly c5 opens and this king
is exposed a little bit
it's becoming really sharp and this is
uh what um i was supposed to do
and like look for like some some
complications
uh if king a4
right now this king on a4 is also a
little bit misplaced now knight d7
for instance and some ideas of
knight c5 check maybe b5 again the
knight c5 are all there
still white is slightly better here but
it's
by far not clear for instance analyze
rook taxi a rook takes e8
rook d2 uh seemingly
natural but already not so clear because
um y wants to defend poland
two if king a5 rook a8 for instance
right so this could be the problem so
that's why rook d2 has to be played
or like should be played if bishop a5 uh
you know bishop goes under the spin so
like suddenly also anything can happen
like rook a8 maybe b6 can happen
uh all kinds of nice c5 checks that's
you know
particular move orders but like it's
become but but most most importantly
regards just pins and
there is no way to get out of this pin
because if king before
of course bc just wins a piece so there
are certain issues that white has to
resolve here so rook d2
is logical but not so easy to to be
played over the board
so let's say b6 king a3 and okay rook c8
and suddenly we simplify the position a
little bit
white king is not going to be six square
as it was earlier always happen
it was going there it's not so clear
let's say after this we can just play
rook e8
we keep it solid as black we try to play
solid
and here we go again with this bishop on
f5 which is very very strong
and bishop on f1 um is not on the other
hand if we
would come back to a few moves to the
position where alejandro could play
bishop d3 my bishop would be always
terrible on a6
right now it's very good actually on f5
so that's the main difference in
all those lines so in this position
however i didn't play a5 i played with a
97
um rook d2
back i played rook e7 i thought
okay like i will just try to play so
maybe double my rooks on the e file
bishop d6 uh and uh e8
and here again uh alejandro probably was
supposed to play move like
uh bishop c7 back and then try to play
king a5
uh but uh here he made suddenly a
mistake
c5 this was a horrible move and moves
like bishop c7 for instance back and
then maybe you know control this a5 idea
somehow it will be seven and then
uh you know let's say king a5 looks
logical as well
such play would be you know pretty
sensible let's say k5 here for instance
one of many moves obviously however
after c5 suddenly of course alejandro
wants to play king a5 if i allow king a5
i will be lost
but if i play right now fa5 we get
similar position to what
we just discussed i could play a5
earlier
and actually i didn't see i didn't
mention one line so i will just get back
in a second
after a5 bishop a5 there is small uh
tactics
involving c5 i should mention this
because after king b5 bishop d7
and white has to give up the exchange
because king b6
is phased by is made by either rook a6
or e6
and the pawn bishop one a5 is just
gone probably uh
[Music]
if i
um yeah rook a6 or
both moves probably are good probably
your k6 is a little bit stronger than
that
um and if this this suddenly
exchange is you know what black has an
exchange
why has huge compensation for his
exchange let's say rook d2 would listen
i have to run away somewhere bishop d3
may come out
but it is not by any means
clear like i would be very happy if i
had such you know
messy position out of this terrible end
game that i had
before coming back to the game rook ed2
rookie seven bishop d6 rook e8
c5 video king a5 but it is way too slow
i could
right now play a5 i don't allow king a5
obviously and after a5
king c3 i had a chance basically to
very quickly basically instantly
equalize
rook e3 right now is a very strong move
that i unfortunately didn't play
and the idea is that if king b2 i can
just
follow through with a4 and
it suddenly you know white has dwight
doesn't have anything special like i
i can always bring my knight to e5 my
bishop 25 is very well placed as well
uh i challenge pawn structure on the
queen side
and my rooks are on a8 and e3 very
active as well
so there is i don't see any reason for
me to worry in this position apart from
them this fact that still there's pair
of bishops maybe at some point and
will be a problem but as of now is not
the problem at all because i have
sufficient compensation in terms of
active
active pieces and if king d4 is also
is a little bit shaky because suddenly
rook 88 and this king on d4 is
sort of loose there could be some mating
ideas
of course pretty far-fetched still there
is no any access there but it's becoming
a little bit shaky for white king at
least at least visually so
[Music]
i don't think black has any any problems
here
so while i play 95 which was inaccuracy
still is not a huge inaccuracy position
is already sort of balanced rookie free
but it was just more accurate 95 is a
little bit inaccurate but still it's
quite okay
a4 knight f7 happened bishop c7 will
give ruby seven
bishop b6 now i played rookie free
kim b2 as you can see all those lines i
have some compensation right now in
terms of you know
uh my active active rogue on e3 and so
on
uh so i played 95 very logical move and
now alejandra played rookie two
and unfortunately here i made a mistake
um because i missed the next alejandro
next move
alejandro played i played with
d3 which was a mistake the idea was of
course i
i was hoping sort of uh for if rook
takes d3 bishop takes d3 for instance
and i can
take it trade the light square bishops
and i'll be doing great
and if alejandro let's say plays let's
say rook de1 or something i'll play
bishop e6 hitting on b3 so i thought he
has to you know
i'll be doing at least okay here and if
he plays rook ed2 then i can just simply
come back and i don't have any problems
here whatsoever
but uh here as a surprise uh came
that he played rook e1 and i
do not have a free square anymore for my
rook
and uh unfortunately i have i'm forced
to trade at some point the rooks
and he's trading my very active rogue on
d3 for you know
not not amazing not he's not amazing
on d1 and i'm left with my pawn weak
pawn on a5 suddenly
and the rugan a8 which is also not
not not an active piece around this time
we're already
like around one minute so there were
lots of things happening
uh it was moved on move number 40. so
lots of mistakes were happening we're
both playing on like five second
increment
and such time control and having so
little time
pretty much this is like a coin flip
anything can happen and as
we will see this endgame was just a joke
instead if you said rook d3 like what
happened later i mean
i could have played knight d3 and the
idea is very nice because i simply
improved my knight to bear squares as
white already played with c4 c5 earlier
right now d5 square is available for my
knight if i can reroute my knight there
no reason to worry at all here for me so
king a3 let's say takes takes knight f4
bishop of 195 for instance it's just
totally okay for black
no any problems whatsoever just a
blockade powerful knight on d5
05 is a prop is a weakness still but
here there is no way to exploit that
because bishop on b6 is out of game
although he's not participating in the
game as well apart from the fact that
it's
uh challenges but if i keep keep keeps
my rook there
hasn't it has no any attacking value so
uh let's say bishop c4 i can play uh at
least already 93
but i can also just play if i want to
play super solid as black i can just
play bishop b6 not the best move
probably
i can play super so just printing f7 no
problems whatsoever here for
for for me and this is what i
was supposed to do i kind of missed that
uh
as i missed many things in this game uh
rook d3
rookie one rook takes d1 or takes d1 uh
and now i decide to king f7 i tried to
bring my king
but it already is you know here i'm
backwards again because i play king
king f7 because i was worried about all
kinds sort of ideas gonna connect with
rook d8
try to trade with his rooks and then put
my opponent if i will be
falling um and
as a valid concern that i had here still
in this position after king f7 rook d8
wasn't probably possible because of this
this and now i can
actually give this power i'll be happy
to give this pawn as long as i can trade
my devos bishops
let's say and right after this this uh
first of all i can recapture on c5 any
moment i want and i
can also go for for for this guy and for
knight g2
so that's a king c5 neither four is
massive
is possible but also and so is neither
four and a knight takes g2
and here you know anything can happen
it's becoming really sharp and i don't
think black has any reasons to worry in
design game
so uh rook dj will be premature that's
why king c3
and now i was my my idea was to bring
king to e7 to cover
uh the a square from from white's rook
but it runs into all sort of checks with
bishop d6 and this is what exa alejandro
exactly this is what exactly 100 does
bishop c7 bishop v6
comes and i'm in trouble i'm
i'm back in trouble again uh i play
bishop b6
which is i thought a good move but uh
you know rookie one right because i have
to sort of deal with
rookie one next move and i wanted to uh
by playing with v6 to cover is the the e
file
after this display moved knight uh g6
and the idea was after bishop c4 knight
effect they've
tried very passive defense but at least
king f7 and
sort of i didn't see how he can how
alejandro could possibly crush me
immediately
unfortunately though there is a way so
this my this mistake was uh
kind of kind of big for me here and this
position
i would like to actually take a moment
and discuss
this a little bit more because clearly
white is better uh
only five is hanging pawnify is a
weakness
[Music]
and i'm not to be honest it's not so
easy to uh to make a move here from
practical practical perspective for for
black
um moves like knight f7 of course are
bad because of bishop c4
there is a spin on the e file but if we
look at this position from different
perspective
like um
if we uh because the point what i'm
trying to say is
what is white's plan let's say uh if i
don't do anything
what is white's plan uh assuming that
there is no bishop to 85 is there
anything that white the white wants
and to be honest i struggle to find an
idea for instance if before a takes
before king taste before
doesn't really doesn't really lead
anywhere
um white can never activate easily this
bishop from f1 at least it will take a
long time because the bishop d1
sorry bishop e2 bishop d1 bishop c2
would take three moves to improve this
knight
sorry bishop and still not clear where
it is going
um f4 right now is not possible g3 is
not possible
um you know it's not easy to come up
with like some suggestion for
uh for wider disposition uh apart from
bishop to z5
so the while my main threat is basically
right now to take the cup to capture
only five and win upon
but the problem is the the difficult
part of this end game here
is to understand uh that after bishop
takes e5
it is not so clear whether this white
wants to even do that yes it wins upon
but
for instance if i play with king f7 just
ignore because this was stunning
uh at least my stunning discovery i did
during the analysis
uh if k7 takes stakes rotate if i can
get six
let's just let's see what's this
position first of all the pawns on the
dark squares here
uh sorry i'll put on the green color g5
h4
and they are strictly covering all the
dark squares on the
on a queen side sorry king side
and it's impossible to push white pawns
forward easily
but also white pawn on g2 could
potentially also become a weakness
if i manage to bring my king there in
the future
of course it's very far-fetched this too
is
you know it's uh it's only hypothetical
but it's possible but technically it's
possible um
also my problem if it's not a weakness
anymore
because there is no dark square bishops
so even though i
i lost a pawn my position got more even
because um of course i'm i'm
why this is better i'm not saying the
white is not bad but it's still better
of course it's just extra pawn
however it is not easy to convert this
at all
uh for i don't have any weaknesses any
major practices
uh paul pawn effects on the weakness as
i said and i want to play very quickly
move just rook d8 and activate my pieces
total like
to the to the total uh to for them to
reach their full potential
for instance rook e4 just rook d8
poland be free like uh is also uh some
object of the attack in the future
possibly let's say d4 is not possible
because takes takes
uh and bishop takes be free right
so this already is not possible
if move something like before or
something like this
white black can consider at least move
rook d1 and suddenly activate the rook
give some check from behind
if bishop e2 possibly and one of the
ideas could be
maybe at some point rook g1 maybe not
now maybe let's say
after taking b4 or maybe rook c1
throwing one in one check there
but idea of rook g1 here
maybe maybe even now why not why not
after b takes a five
would be a rotation to stand upon a
trace hanging as well
it's not entirely clear what's going on
it can go either way
white black suddenly gets some
compensation and
it is definitely not what white normally
wanted from this end game to be
um especially you know that the big
the big part of the advantage right now
is pair of bishops and that my pieces
are totally cramped
after bishop x5 white wins the pawn
but my pieces suddenly are alive so this
one trying to say activity in the end
game
is very important and sometimes it
not sometimes but very often it balances
the
the material so if you
if if you if black right now is pawn
down
the compensation for respawn will be
very active pieces coming rookie king f6
and rook d8 white plexus are suddenly
perfectly placed
while here but they were pretty passive
the sergeant is totally awful right
it can never be activated because with
this bishop on c7
and so therefore in this position if i
just stay in place king of seven
i'm not entirely sure what is the best
follow-up here for white uh normally it
should be bishop to x5 but as we
discussed
it is not easy and is not an easy end
game to
uh to win there uh for for white
so but yeah liking sm requires
huge understanding and also time on the
clock
uh because
even if you have greater than say in the
world but you have no time to basically
evaluate it quickly
it doesn't matter basically so uh
here we both had like around one minute
so
the level five basically dropped
significantly down
so uh i played knight g6 bishop c4
knight f8
and right now the 100 played the most
natural
move which majority of people would play
and this move is bishop d6
and this is an inaccuracy again
considering that there is such amazing
pin on this e file white has time to
basically develop the initiative in
other direction
and suddenly it's time to basically
raise second weakness on the king side
on the rule about endgames create two
weaknesses if you have
if you open the evol point uh or defend
side that is defending there's only one
weakness
like right now my only weakness pawn on
a5 uh
i'll put the red marker uh yeah my only
poisonous pawn on a5
if this pawn is guarded like okay i will
play
king f7 we should maybe try bishops play
knight e6 if you don't trade bishops
uh i'll just play you know bishop d5
knight maybe 96 or maybe not g6 or
whatever i can sort of maybe hold
because only there are only one weakness
to
to to defend on the other hand
if uh after f4
what creates second weakness on the
other wing like
on the on the king's eye right now
it may be too much to handle pretty much
after let's say g takes a
f4 after this uh one of the
possibilities to play here as well would
be to play f5 one of the possibilities
not only but
one of them also rookie 6 just wins on
the spot
k96 f5 just game over
so kf7 is not not possible
but even even this move f5 here like it
would be decent
because the right now beat xc4 suddenly
pawn b7 is totally dominated
rook b1 could could happen so many
weaknesses also
pawn five is dominating all those
squares
well probably just what is just winning
here uh so
rookie 6 win on the spot but f5 also
positional is just overwhelming
uh even king takes c4 is possible just
just to
like let's say this and even right now
bishop's d6 because if rogue 8 we can
just take and
bishop goes back to c7 0.5 false this
game
ends game is simply winning for white as
i said
there are two weaknesses suddenly uh
here one weakness is the e file is
suddenly white controls
so black has to face it but then the
other weakness falls b7
a5 for instance of course this is
hypothetical like
just saying for example lines um
but yeah just yeah just for educational
purposes
so gtx4 um
if if if gta x4 bishop takes the f4
uh king e6 sorry king f7 and bishop d6
right now we can see right now this pawn
on h4 is
totally weak it's just very weak
pawn and the pawn of his also is weak
rookie four idea will
very likely be crushing for analyze a
little bit
this further rook e8 and
white actually can already win in many
ways one of the let's say the most uh
forceful ways to win this is to go for a
pawn in the game bishop takes f8 and
this is just purely
exam for example like there are other
ways to win this with us white
but just already for like for example y
can already transfer to the pokemon game
which is one which is winning
should activate which will take c4 who
takes e8 king takes e8
pawn takes c4 uh and now king goes
forward
king d4 king e4 and the king f4 and this
end game is simply winning for
white after f5 uh why can't we by
playing king e5 king g5 king d6 only
going to b7 pawn
and then this game was simply a little
bit faster f4
uh c6 f2 c7 cf one c8 queen
punished around the right now is guarded
post four is guarded pawn a5 falls
even though actually black promoted
first but
it doesn't matter because while white
has extra pawn and our pawn on a5 is is
falling down
so uh why this is simply winning in this
queen end game
of course it's not necessary just
showing for example one of the examples
we know continuations here so
anyway a foreign disposition creates
second weakness which is the
very important you know a strategy to
know
um and i don't know what i would do
after this
probably alejandra would win the game
however alejandro played bishop d6
king f7 and suddenly you know it's not
so clear because this after this i take
this and
we just straight pieces and these those
traits are in my favor
i think so alejandro decided to keep
this on the board bishop d3 still is
much better for white
but it's becoming less and less clear
uh rookie 8
bishop c7 back and this was already
sort of inaccuracy and here i ca
you know one of the very nice ideas here
for white was to play move like rook b1
and idea is to play move b4 uh but
again this was impossible to find over
you know
like few seconds decision so bishop 7 is
very natural move
regard back and yeah
right now basically we're playing on
less than one minute we play like in 20
seconds so i don't want to discuss you
know some
uh everything about what was happening
because it's pretty much irrelevant the
level was simply horrible we were just
trying to make a move make moves in
order not to lose on time
so uh f4 rook c8
um bishop d6 takes takes stakes
only this f4 move was premature probably
alejandro had to go back we should b6
try to you know keep it together
and uh yeah just just play it and
probably after get
finally go through b1 uh but uh yeah f4
was probably
here a mistake because after looks here
i've challenged this bishop
and after uh bishop d6 pawn takes f4
if he takes on f4 suddenly is not
entirely clear because i can play bishop
d5 knight d6
and i bring my pieces out
and this will happen actually in the
game uh rookie 2 knight d6 i bring my
pieces to the game so it's not the same
example as earlier f4 i'll bring it
again
f4 here where i'm totally cramped here
on this
ifa i'm totally cramped i'm basically
just lost uh
if i like my pieces are horrible in
f4 later as in the game in this position
is already a different story
besides bishop d5996 i get my pieces out
and
becomes very unclear rugby 2 96 bishop
d6 okay right now rook g8 obviously i
need to activate my rook
we should be 5 logical to stop bishop
bishop and rook to h2 but after rugby g5
i'm not worries anymore for sure
uh bishop on g5 uh bishop on f5 is under
attack
and if bishop takes e6 bishop 86 there
is different oppo
i mean opposite color bishops and this
is saying i definitely have
no no reasons to worry alejandro
in severe time travel play bishop g4 and
only severe time travel you know uh
justify such terrible move because after
f5
it should be three takes i've managed
three bishops
and after f4 i am simply actually
winning because i'm faster right now to
create the
attacking spawns with rook g3 and also
on c5
is not like you know it's not very i
don't care about spawn c5
but rude free right now is a huge idea
for me that i'm
you know i'm simply winning right now so
i haven't played before trying to play
counterplay
rook g3 i just ignore uh collect
and i play okay free trying to you know
because i have like c4 i guess to play
rugby b2 then and
hit this pawn so i want to attack his a4
pawn
to force his king to go to b4 and again
i made 13 right now in this winning
position for me
i've made terrible blunder because i
played rook takes h3
which is again very automatic move uh
you know the only time travel explains
that because right now after move like
bishop takes f4
the game would end with pretty much the
draw because not after 94 would have two
and i'm pinned he goes back tonight and
this rook end game should be drawn
still i may have some slight chances to
win this but objectively should be
should be a draw uh instead alejandro
played group
okay instead instead of rocket takes a
chance to play probably just f3
and after uh rook f2 focus on pushing
the pawn forward bringing the knight
knight g5 knight
to h3 or knight g95 knight to e4
simply push the pawn and the game is
decided uh
for instance a6 takes king a59 g5
if bishop f4 does not takes h3 if this
this
and h3 and the pawns are pretty much too
advanced they're just promoting the
queen
so um yeah after rook takes h3
unfortunately uh
a hundred people had opportunity to play
bishop takes a four which would end
with immediate draw or nearly immediate
draw but 100
play in both we were both in like seared
and some trouble like
we had maybe i don't know 10 seconds
with five seconds increment it was it
was nuts
very much so rugby 2 rook d3
and king c4 rook d4
king c3 rook takes a4 king group b7 king
g6 all normal
and a6 trying to i don't know
push the pawn forward or something and
the funny thing is that
in this position i can the simplest
weight is just to ignore this
upon the a pawn because it's blocked
it's same way stopped by my rug and just
push h3 and h2 and just decide it game
is over
i have extra pawn but um the i've
simply two passers that are like going
forward and there is no way to stop them
uh effectively i decided today which is
all swing at path room b6 at least i
have some practical dilemma right now
and here i made horrible mistake again
maybe five seconds
i had i don't know how much time i had
but you know literally a few seconds
and i played quickly this is something
seeing that after this this 98 i simply
stopped the spawn
and i thought like somehow win with my
pawns there
well it's just simply lose spoiling the
entire
that entire game because uh after
rook b6 takes knight d8 bishop before
king f5 bishop d7
king d4 uh bishop is
first of all i lost one of my pawns
second thing bishop stops this pawn
and if i ever go with my king to the
king towards the king side
i will my white king will go to
my queen side and challenge this pawn
c69 from an iphone b7
and uh it is simply a draw right now
so just to quickly show what i could
have done instead
after b6 the simplest by far the
simplest
it was to simply eliminate the pawn
eliminate the pawn knight xc5 game is
decided the game is over
nothing to pretty much discuss because
affirmation takes b6 takes takes
pawns are pretty much promoting h3
bishop bg1 only move f3
f2 h2 uh just deciding king d3 let's say
f2 and h2 h1 queen like
uh just horrendous that i didn't play
knight xc5 which was by far the easiest
there are other moves that were winning
just do not trade the rooks just do not
trade the rogues and push h pawn
uh game over rook a3
very likely the easiest also move apart
from knight xc5
anyway i played rook takes b6 uh again
it was all time trouble right now
knight d8 with my bishop f4 king f5
and in this game end game suddenly after
king e4 a very strong move
i do not have a passage with my king
towards the g2
and the the only way to create this
passage is to push the c
pawn and i did this after c5 uh i mean
king e4 just goes back and i find in the
first place if i buff king d5 right now
i'm simply too slow to uh to win this
game uh
king white's king is white has enough
contemplative king c6 here freaking
let's say bishop e5 king g2 king c6 it's
more than sufficient counterplay
i tried c4 and c3 but this
we both promote right now but this is
just
there is no way to i could win that in
the game anything with a draw
so yeah so this is it for
for today i think it was crazy game it
was crazy game
uh lots of mistakes from both sides
mostly because of the time pressure that
we both
encountered at the in the middle game
and the end game
uh actually the the game started with
number nine or something so it was very
very long yeah actually
uh no move number number eleven since
this position the game started
at move number eleven uh so uh
unfort like it was very long game
a really long end game i was defending
for majority of it they had my chances i
spoiled spoiled them in general uh
just to sum it up this game it was a
circus
but there were nonetheless several
interesting positions let's say
to create second weakness to push the uh
to bring the king to b6 for white uh
many many times um
[Music]
and i think the most important kind of
like to keep
the head and they keep the stay calm in
such let's say time scramble and so on
because then
anything can happen and
[Music]
as in this game as this game showed
i spoiled winning chances and so also i
saw that alejandro uh earlier in the
middle game where he
went to little one time and uh
made a mistakes that were pretty much
hard to explain because
um such stronger alejandro should
normally with such engages too
so yeah that's all from me from today
but insane in the end game because
indeed insane end game
i'll be back next week with
anything in the game insane in the end
game again but tomorrow
and the others will be another stream
where i will be
so stay tuned